I'm still in my kid asked that it be
that have to say I don't understand
called grandpa or I am going to say this
guy is because in space there are these
gigantic birds like Terry battle that
ended and over that atmosphere except
when they are state with a gray and that
is white house are gray there are signs
the disease and I believe deep down in
there these birds that for leading the
world in of the fact the color of our
sky and I will be a failure
good morning John that was a dramatic
reading of YouTube's Auto captioning of
a video in which you implore me to teach
you son about science because otherwise
he'll ask you all this guy's Lewin knows
how I'm the story about pterodactyl poop
or something one thing is very clear
google / YouTube's auto-captioning right
now is very bad you can turn it on by
clicking down here on the CC button and
it sliding over and you can see how bad
it is auto captioning me right now
generally right now Google's Auto
captioning is Donald report back with an
elephant fat but there's no denying that
they're getting better at it and Google
like it or not has in-depth analytical
access to the world's largest database
of recorded spoken words which is
YouTube kind of strange to think of it
that way but that is one of the things
that YouTube is they also have a very
deep well of talent very deep pockets
and strong economic incentives for being
able to figure out the words that are
coming out of my mouth go to vine the
lady that held the Brotherhood's web
servers if they can't figure out what
I'm talking about they can run some ads
down here and over here it's talking
about exactly the stuff that I'm talking
about this contextual ad thing is how
Google makes all of its money so they
would like to be able to do that with
video they also want us to be able to
talk into our phones which I can do
right now Google is sometimes kind of
creepy Google is the first kind of
creepy and that's pretty amazing
robot Nita I am a role model what are
your genes but there are broader
implications in this technology that
kind of creeped me out
unfortunately for Google understanding
what words are being said and
understanding what those words mean when
strung together into a sentence are
completely different tasks and one of
them which we're talking about right now
is quite difficult I have recently
exciting sex if the Senate lasts a
couple days but understanding the
meaning of the sentence turns out to be
even harder Google has very strong
economic incentives to figure out what
sentences mean and so far they've been
proof
be unable to do that even with those
deep pockets and all that talent Google
is completely unable to turn a sentence
like the one I'm saying right now into
useful information the software would be
required to do far too much analysis and
synthesis of information on its own and
there's so much cultural context that
goes into all the stuff that we say in
the tone of our voice if the program
could actually understand and synthesize
data from these complex sentences that
would pretty much be artificial
intelligence I think that we
dramatically underestimate the
complexity of our own brains and
artificial intelligence would require us
to write the software that runs our
brains and we have no idea how our
brains work but that does not mean that
100 percent accurate speech recognition
would not have huge implications for the
world if speech recognition were 100
percent accurate for two different
languages subtitling conversations using
handheld devices or even in ear or ni
devices would become trivial except that
the translations would of course be
machine based and thus not entirely
accurate as anyone who has used Google
Translate can tell you but combining
speech recognition with an actual Bionic
implant of a kind which doesn't actually
to me seem all that far off would I
think have really dramatic implications
on what it means to be a person and
anybody who hasn't thought about that
should read this book it's called feed
so yes these funny little snippets of
wrongly translated text are funny
they're cute they're bad and we talk way
too fast for them to understand us but
that is just right now and if we know
anything about how technology works it
probably won't be too long before they
figure it out so it is probably very
worth you and I is thinking about what
that will mean when it does work what it
means when Chinese cover president has
heeded his advice from the beginning
John I'll see you on way
as a countdown day by day
yes you are right